today's video is sponsored by a test the
consumer research platform find out more
later in the video hey 42 here
unless you've spent your life in a cave
eating bats
and admiring your semi-translucent skin
you've probably heard
of the legend of the lost city of
atlantis
said to have existed about eleven and a
half thousand years ago
atlantis was a utopian civilization
founded by
demigods the island was rich in gold
silver precious metals and exotic
wildlife
and over time the atlanteans who lived
there
grew into a mighty naval power and an
advanced
society but in a sadly familiar story
the people of atlantis became greedy and
morally bankrupt
so the gods sent them a gift a night of
cataclysmic destruction
involving earthquakes and volcanic
eruptions so
violent they sank atlantis to the bottom
of the sea
never to be seen again unlike the city
of atlantis
you won't be lost in the ocean of
business
when you use a test the consumer
research platform
ambitious businesses you know the ones
they get ahead by
understanding their ever-changing
customers what they think
how they behave and why they buy
but how do you get to be one of those
businesses
that's where a test comes in a test
gives you the clarity you need
to make the choices for your customers
that supercharge your business
it's rocket fuel for decision makers you
bring the questions
for example who is my target customer is
my brand activity working
and will this creative hit the mark and
the test
brings the answers in the style of a
consumer research platform
that's easy to use coupled with
reporting that's quick
and insightful attests in-house experts
will help you
ask the right questions and draw the
best conclusions
with data that is checked and verified
not once not twice but three times over
making sure that in a world of too much
information
you are able to cut through to what you
need and stand out
a test puts that power in your hands
they allow you to test every hunch
remove all doubt
and most of all grow without guess work
so to get started with a test today head
over to askatest.com
forward slash 42 or just click the link
below in the description
that's askatest.com forward slash 42
and start growing your business today
this is all according to greek
philosopher plato by the way
he first told that story around 360 bc
unfortunately though it seems his
writings
are the only records of this tragic
event
it's sort of like one of those
situations where you end up getting
stuck next to some guy you don't know
it's a wedding he won't stop banging on
about how he invented memory foam
but nasa stole the idea from him when he
was drunk
it's highly unlikely but you just can't
disprove it
most scientists and historians agree
plato
made the story of atlantis up as a
vehicle to teach some of his
philosophical ideas namely that pride
comes before an earthquake
but there have always been those who
believe
atlantis was real unfortunately though
they can't agree on where it was the
smart money
if you can call it that is on the greek
island of santorini in the aegean sea
around three and a half thousand years
ago the island was home to an advanced
civilization
called the minoans who appear to have
been wiped out by a massive volcanic
eruption
which sounds like a pretty great fit
with the atlanta's story
apart from the minor issue that the two
events took place around
6 000 years apart other suggested
locations for atlantis have included
bermuda the bahamas peru
india crete turkey britain
sweden gibraltar indonesia
the middle of the atlantic ocean or
maybe even antarctica
in other words it could be anywhere i
would say scientists have been debating
the topic for decades but it turns out
they've had much more important
questions to answer
such as what happens when you fast in
space
no the whereabouts of the lost city of
atlantis
are mostly argued over by people in
captains
who listened to too much donovan in the
60s luckily for them though the answer
was finally revealed in 2014
by academy award-winning actress shirley
maclaine
according to mclean atlantis was
originally situated in the
area that we now know as the canary
islands
a realization that apparently came to
her while she was there on a film shoot
maclean says she's had visions of past
lives in atlantis
which she describes as a huge island
continent
built by so-called star nations
in case you're not up to speed with your
celestial being
terminology star people are said to have
either been
enlightened aliens or their descendants
who are hiding amongst us
ready to usher in a new age of joy and
prosperity for humankind
introduced by brad steiger in his 1976
book
gods of aquarius the star people have
become
a beloved trope of new agers and other
people who like
singing crystals but if you listen to
mclean talk she doesn't
necessarily strike you as someone who at
any moment may
try to sell you a dream catcher or burst
into a chorus of kumbaya
she has a very no-nonsense pragmatic air
about her
as she describes the many past lives she
can remember
from countries around the world and
periods across time
could it be that she's onto something
are shirley maclaine's recollections of
past
lives accurate in other words
could reincarnation be real
like the concept of life after death
plenty of people around the world
believe in reincarnation
you might associate the idea with
religions like buddhism
and hinduism which include the idea that
we're all part of a cycle
of death and rebirth tied to our actions
in life
our karma but reincarnation has also
gained a larger following in the west in
recent times
thanks to practices like past life
regression
an experience under hypnosis in which
you begin to recall
or even relive past lives
fans of the process say they're
transported back into the past
sometimes thousands of years where they
see the world
through the eyes of cleopatra or a
second world war soldier
or a russian peasant girl or a medicine
man who sells fake therapies to people
unfortunately there isn't a shred of
evidence to support the validity of past
life regression
all we have to go on are the stories of
those who've been through the therapy
and since many of those people believe
in reincarnation in the first place
that's hardly an objective data set
the thing is if you really were say the
reincarnation of someone
who lived hundreds even thousands of
years ago
you ought to possess some pretty bloody
useful information about humanity's past
you might be able to speak a long dead
language for example
or no details about the climate or
geopolitical situation in your era or
perhaps the customs of civilizations
that fell
before written records began those who
have undergone
past life regression are suspiciously
unable to provide information
on any of these things for the obviously
simple reason
that the only past lives they've
actually ever lived
are an old save file of the sims
don't get me wrong i'm not trying to
make some bold statements about
reincarnation in general
it's a bit more complicated than that as
we're about to find out
i'm just saying that if someone who
really wants to believe in reincarnation
undergoes past life regression you can
be pretty darn sure they're going to end
up with some
incredible past life origin story about
being an ancient prince or some other
important historical figure
i'd actually be more inclined to believe
in the whole thing if there are a few
more
devastated reincarnated hitlers and pol
pots knocking around
none of this is to say that everyone who
undergoes hypnosis and wakes up
believing they used to be elvis is
intentionally trying to deceive
themselves
or others they're simply the victims of
human memory
if you've been following the channel
recently you'll know that we're all
surprisingly susceptible to remembering
things
that never actually happened for
something you probably see
as a non-fiction repository of your own
life story
your memory is actually extremely
creative
filling in blanks and connecting dots to
create
a comprehensible story of the past even
when parts of that past never actually
took place
and it's this flair for invention that
is probably behind
many claimed instances of reincarnation
several studies have demonstrated that
people who believe they have lived past
lives are significantly more likely to
create
false memories than the rest of us one
and
donors and a natural propensity to
create false memories
isn't only common in people who believe
they've experienced past lives either
it turns out we've seen the exact same
thing with people who claim they've been
abducted by
aliens so yeah that sore ass you've been
telling everyone about
may just be hemorrhoids after all it's
also been shown that the very act of
undergoing past life regression itself
increases your susceptibility to forming
false memories for this reason the vast
majority of medical practitioners
consider it to not only be unscientific
but flat-out unethical since it violates
a key part of the hippocratic oath to do
no harm
as i've said just because past life
regression
appears to be a pseudo science that
doesn't mean reincarnation is
automatically made up
too and there certainly seem to be
plenty of reincarnation claims
that have nothing to do with past life
regression or hypnotism
for example the dalai lama the spiritual
leader of tibet
is regarded in his religion as the 14th
reincarnation
of a past llama or spiritual leader
who wish to be reborn to continue his
work
in tibetan buddhism the search for the
new dalai lama
begins as soon as the previous one dies
and
it really is a surge in the case of
tenzin gayatso the current
dalai lama it took four years
to locate the new dalai lama the high
llamas of the religious order
look for signs including dreams or
visions from lamo lazzo
the sacred lake these signs should lead
the llamas to the boy
they believe to be the dalai lama's
reincarnation
they then show him a mix of objects some
of which belonged to the previous dalai
lama
and if the boy manages to accurately
pick out his old gear
it's regarded as proof that he is indeed
the reincarnated llama it's said that
tenzin gayatso for example apparently
picked out a bell
and prayer beads belonging to the 13th
dalai lama
by shouting it's mine it's mine
then there's the story of the pollock
twins in 1957
two sisters jacqueline and joanna
pollock
were tragically killed in a car accident
their parents
were understandably devastated but the
next year they fell
pregnant with twins jennifer and jillian
pollock
shortly after the twins birth the family
moved away from the town in which their
first two children had been raised
but when they moved back a few years
later
the surviving twins started pointing out
landmarks they could not possibly have
recognized
since they are only three months old
when they left
not long after they started asking for
toys that had belonged to their deceased
sisters despite never having seen the
toys before
and they are also said to get hysterical
when they saw
moving cars there's also the story of
dorothy edie
also known as om seti dorothy was born
near london
in january 1904 and for the first few
years of her life she had a regular
childhood
then at the age of three she had a
terrible fall down the stairs
and was pronounced dead miraculously
an hour later she sat up in bed
but from that day on there was something
different about her
not long after the accidents the family
visited the british museum
where dorothy became transfixed by the
displays of ancient egypt
she began kissing the feet of the
statues and
when her mother tried to take her away
dorothy begged to be allowed to stay
with
what she called her people in the time
that followed dorothy had recurring
dreams
of a particular building with columns
surrounded by rich vegetation
she would also have episodes of intense
sadness during which she would
beg her parents to take her home
even though she was already in her home
then
one day dorothy was looking through some
pictures of ancient egypt
when she found an image of the temple of
seti the first
at abidos the picture matched the images
in dorothy's dreams
and she ran to her father telling him
she'd finally found her home
dorothy went on to study egyptology and
eventually married an egyptian
and moved to cairo where she had a child
who she named
seti around this time she began a
strange practice called
automatic writing according to her
husband she would get up in the middle
of the night in a trance-like state
and write out pages of hieroglyphics
over the course of 12 months
she filled more than 70 pages with this
writing
which outlined her past life as a
priestess
in ancient egypt in great detail
if by now you're rolling your eyes and
muttering things about brits getting too
much sun
you're not alone dorothy edie was met
with plenty of skepticism about her
supposed past life
but in 1956 she took a job in the
antiquities department at abidos the
place she believed she'd lived in her
previous life
it was after moving here that she took
to being called
omseti meaning mother of seti
in one visit to the temple the chief
inspector from the antiquities
department
spontaneously tested cessy's claim of
reincarnation
by telling her to go in complete
darkness
and stands next to specific wall
paintings
using only her supposed knowledge of the
temple
she passed the test despite the fact the
locations of those paintings
had never been published she later told
archaeologists where to find the remains
of the temple garden
and she also pointed excavators to a
hidden tunnel
at the northern end of the temple which
nobody had known about before
stories like these are hard to swallow
because
we assume there must be another
explanation but some pretty credible
scientists are suggesting that
events like this could be possible
to be fair they're actually talking
about a scientific basis
for the existence of consciousness but
that's essentially what reincarnation is
the continuation of some form of
consciousness
from one life to another in 1931
nobel prize-winning physicist and father
of quantum theory
max planck declared that he regarded
consciousness as
the fundamental essence that gave rise
to mata
what this actually means in practice is
a bit of a mystery
but at the heart of this somewhat
oblique idea
is one of the biggest discussions in
physics today
is the mind a mere byproduct of brain
activity and the physical properties of
the brain
or is human consciousness something more
a physical thing in and of itself
that functions and exists in ways we
don't
really understand yet that might sound
like the kind of nonsense that
scientists will come out
after tripping on magic mushrooms but
some of the brightest minds in human
history people like
irwin schrodinger and werner heisenberg
alongside
planck have pondered this very question
and come out thinking that the laws of
physics
as we know them can't entirely explain
human consciousness and ultimately
if we don't really understand what
consciousness
is the existence of a soul
and by extension things like
reincarnation
can't be definitively ruled out
of course not definitively ruling
something out
certainly doesn't mean it's true but it
leaves the door of possibility open
just a crack before now reincarnation
like all questions about what happens
after we die
is impossible to settle for certain our
knowledge of physics
biology and the universe simply isn't
quite there yet
perhaps we will find some way to test
this scientifically in the future
but personally i have my doubts and
there is one small issue with the idea
of reincarnation that i haven't
mentioned yet
the maths doesn't add up right now we
have almost 8 billion people
on this planet but 250 years ago
there were fewer than 1 billion if
everyone is reincarnated
where did the extra 7 billion souls come
from
if you happen to be the reincarnation of
albert einstein
perhaps you could just kindly drop the
answer in the comments below
thanks and thanks for watching check out
my new podcast
random interesting facts available on
youtube spotify
apple podcast and anywhere else you get
your podcasts
link in the description below thanks